our project here is to try to create an
autonomous race car in fact an
autonomous rally car so a car that can
drive itself around a dirt track or a
paved track really up to the limits of
what is physically possible so race car
drivers are extremely good at using all
of the available friction between the
tire and the road the drive as fast as
possible what we want to do is to
develop safety systems that can use all
of that friction to help you get around
the corner or a boy to spin or any other
situations you might get yourself into
the car is very close to a stock Audi
TTS so the Audi has electric power
steering so we're tapping into the motor
the electric motor that normally assists
the driver we're using it to turn the
wheels by itself it also has an
electronic throttle and electronic
breaks that we're tapping into to be
able to have the vehicle accelerate or
decelerate the way we want it to on top
of that we've added some GPS antennas
which tell us where the car is what
direction is pointing and we also have
some accelerometers and gyroscopes that
tell us how fast we're going how fast
returning there's a small computer in
the trunk that controls all this we have
a laptop that we can use to to change
the program on that control computer so
what we do is we combine all of these
things we take in the sensor
measurements figure out what we want the
car to do and then tell the steering the
brakes and the engine to do what we need
to do in order to get the card to move
in the proper way
Pikes Peak has has been a major
challenge since nineteen sixteen but we
think it's really a great test for our
autonomous rally car see can we make it
up quickly can we go up at race speeds
and can we avoid the nearly ten thousand
foot drops that exist if you're too far
off the design so we are planning on
going up Pikes Peak without anybody in
the car right now when we're in the
field it's safer to have a safety driver
in the car but when we're going up Pikes
Peak for the safety of the testers it's
safer to not have anybody in the car and
so we have to develop the systems to
enable us to go for them so right now
the driver that is in the car is just
there to make sure that things are going
okay and has his hands off the wheel he
puts the button to start the test and
then he'll push the button to stop the
test but they don't interfere with the
driving at all the first star / project
would Stanley was just to see if
autonomous cars could even happen could
you get from point A to point B in the
desert avoiding some obstacles on the
road the second DARPA project with jr.
was could you navigate through a
simulated city obeying the traffic laws
and being able to part pull up the
stoplights make left turns merge all of
those things now with the latest car the
project is can you really control the
car at higher speeds so the previous
vehicles were going 25 40 miles an hour
this car is going 40 hundred and thirty
miles an hour so we really have to know
how to drive the car a little bit better
you